why is it
that you can't england's not doing well
financially right
can't you get a
you call them your mates
they're friends yeah yeah everybody else
in the world
they call them mates sure
get a couple of dozen of your mates and
go down that buckingham palace and kill
the old bag
to what end that's muddy
all right
her majesty [ __ ] question
hey billy burnt tits
i don't know what that means my buddy
has been taking
been asking this same question at
parties before corona the answer always
seems to be pretty evenly split and
causes some lively debates so here it is
do you think the queen of england her
majesty queen elizabeth has given 50
[ __ ] in her life
it can be the same dick
just 50 [ __ ] total i s i said no way
isn't it illegal to touch the queen
yeah i doubt she's out there looking
for a dick to gag on
uh please keep ripping on painters
they're always in the [ __ ] way on the
job sites
sure they feel the same about you um
now whatever your vocation is uh let's
see here uh
50 [ __ ] yeah you know those [ __ ]
rich white people are all freaks she's
probably sucked a dick wearing a goat
head i don't know
why wouldn't she
50 she's like 130.
she gave one [ __ ] every nine years
she'd still be above no that wouldn't
work whatever yeah yeah i think she did
i absolutely think she did
i can't even believe you're debating
that
unless her first husband died really
quickly and she never got over it never
dated again
i don't know that's a weird question i
can't believe that sparked lively debate
i'm trying to remember who the [ __ ] she
is
um
is she still alive
i don't who gives a [ __ ]